كبير المراسلين الطبيين
لشبكة CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا يتجه وجهًا لوجه مع جو
روجان
جو روغان بالطبع هو
مضيف البودكاست المثير للجدل الذي ثبتت
إصابته بالفيروس وتلقى علاجات غير مثبتة
للفيروس وأثار الشكوك مرارًا وتكرارًا
حول اللقاح وانتقد
اللقاحات هنا  قليلاً مما قاله روغان
في الماضي
إذا كنت تبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا
وتقول لي هل يجب أن أتلقى التطعيم ، فأنا لا أذهب إذا
كنت شخصًا يتمتع بصحة جيدة
وتمارس الرياضة طوال الوقت وأنت شاب
و  أنت تأكل جيدًا ومثل لا
أعتقد أنك بحاجة إلى القلق بشأن هذا ، كل
ما تسمعه هو أخذ هذا اللقاح الذي
لا يمنعك حتى من
الإصابة بالمرض أو لا يمكنك الذهاب
إلى الساونا حيث تضاجعك  تريد أن تذهب ،
لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى برودواي لإظهار
أنه جنون
جيدًا في بث جديد اليوم ،
سأل سانجاي روجان عن التطعيم ،
وهنا من
الواضح أن اختبار التبادل يختبرك
لمعرفة ما إذا كان لديك الفيروس ،
والعلاج هو علاجك لأنه
لديك  الفيروس ، نعم ، ما زلت أعتقد أنه سيكون من
الأفضل عدم الإصابة بالفيروس ،
وأعتقد أنه سيكون من الأفضل الإصابة بالفيروس
والتعافي والحصول على مناعة مذهلة
ضده ، أليس من الجيد
أن تمرض؟  أعتقد أنه
يجب عليك فعل ذلك ، أعتقد أنه يجب عليك
التطعيم ثم تمرض ،
وهذا هو السبب لأنه بعد ذلك تحصل على
اللقاح يحميك من
عدوى سيئة ومن ثم تحصل على الرغبة ، وبالتالي تحصل
على المناعة القوية التي يتم
الحصول عليها من الإصابة بالمرض الفعلي نفسه والذي
أكثر تعقيدًا وشمولًا
مما تحصل عليه من اللقاح
الذي يستهدف بروتينًا محددًا ،
يمكنك أن تجعل هذه الحجة أعتقد ، نعم ،
هذه هي الخطوة الصحيحة للحصول على
التطعيم ، ودعها تتلاشى وتتسكع
مع مجموعة من الأشخاص القذرين ،
حسنًا.  بعد ذلك ، احصل على الكثير من
العلاجات في متناول اليد حتى تتمكن
من الاعتناء بها بسرعة ،
وسأرى
توصيتك وأفعلها وأعطيك واحدة خرجت بها
معنا الليلة الماضية ، ربما لم تكن قد
التقطتها ، لقد
فعلت ذلك تقريبًا
الآن وأنا أعلم  أنا أعرف
ما هي خطتك السرية ، ولكن ماذا ولكن آه ،
بالنسبة لك ،
جو روجان نعم ، أود أن أقول إنك حصلت عليها
، والآن احصل على حقنة واحدة من اللقاح ،
لا ، لماذا لا لأن لدي
مناعة أفضل مما كنت سأفعله  لقد تم
تطعيمي ،
حسناً ، سانجاي أعني عدة مرات
حاولت أن أشرح فيها أنني أعني
الأشياء الواضحة لا أحد يعرف كم من الوقت تستمر هذه
المناعة الطبيعية أو كيف تختلف
من شخص لآخر وبالطبع
سيكون أفضل إذا كان لديك
اللقاح علاوة على ذلك ، كل هذه
الحقائق
الأساسية ، هل تشعر وكأنك اخترقت
اللقاح أو أنه سيقبل اللقاح على الإطلاق.
هذا وعندما استشهدت
به بيانات تقول: انظروا
هناك الأشخاص الذين لديهم
مناعة طبيعية أشخاص قاموا بتطعيم
المناعة وبينما
قد تكون المناعة الطبيعية قوية لفترة من
الوقت ، فإن معدلات الإصابة بالعدوى أعلى مرتين
بين الأشخاص الذين لديهم مناعة طبيعية
مقابل اللقاح  كل هذه البيانات حصانة
ولم يتجاهل البيانات
ولكن هذا نوع من ذلك ، أعتقد
أن الشيء الذي فاجأني
أكثر شيء هو أنني أعتقد أنه عندما
تقنع نفسك بسرد معين
في هذه الحالة ، لا يوجد لقاح
لك  ابحث عن أي نوع من الحجة التي
يمكنك دعمها لذلك كانت هناك
دراسة خرجت من إسرائيل تظهر على الأقل
لفترة من الوقت أن الناس لديهم
مناعة قوية من المناعة الطبيعية
ولكن فكرة المدة التي تستغرقها
فكرة ما هي الإصابة مرة أخرى  المعدلات هي
فقط أعتقد أنه لا يريد
سماع ذلك ويمكن أن تسمع أنه كان نوعًا
من المرح حول ذلك آرون كان
يقترح بدلاً منه الذهاب
والحصول على لقاح يجب أن أذهب
لأطمع فيه ، أنا متأكد من أنه  كان يمزح
حول ذلك ولكن يمكنك أن ترى نوعًا
ما ما كنت أتعامل معه هناك